to day five of the interactive learning
workshop and last day sadly and today is
Brian's cousin update from thanks so
much I want to thank everybody this is a
fantastic opportunity the communities
that I circulate in we often value the
solutions that we bring to particular
application problems so I'm gonna give
what would be considered a terrible
robotics talk in that I'm gonna give you
lots of problems and relatively few
solutions but I think that'll be the
best way for us to spark some
interesting conversations and some good
questions now most of the learning that
happens in robotics is based around our
traditional idea of what robots do and
that's based on factory automation the
idea is that we train robots to do
specific tasks to do them with high
accuracy to do them with a large amount
of accuracy of a large amount of uptime
repetitive tasks over and over and over
again and we typically think about this
when we're working in the research lab
as some kind of sequential manipulation
task that is if we're assembling for
example a piece of furniture that we
observe humans dealing with this task
solving this task we characterize that
problem as a sequence of world states
and we then monitor the transitions
between these world States with the hope
of then having a robot being able to
replicate that process by moving from
one state to the other so we build
representations that are these nice easy
to derive representations
from this kind of a linearized example
and that usually ends up with some kind
of semi Markov decision process or some
other flat state based representation
where we observe multiple iterations of
a person putting together this chair and
we end up with this giant mess of states
and part of the problem here is in order
to deal with the complexities of the
world our states have to be very fine
and precisely defined which means we
have a very large dimensional space to
deal with and that means we have lots
and lots of transitions as we go through
even relatively simple tasks and our
goal in robotics is usually to look at
this mess and somehow find an execution
policy for the robot that is what should
the robot do when it's in any one of
these given States in order to complete
the task at hand that's been our
traditional method and that's what we
see in most of robot learning at this
point and we get better and better
representations not just smtps and we
get better and better mechanisms for
reducing the dimensionality and we get
better and better mechanisms for finding
those execution policies but the
challenge that I want to bring to you
today is that as we start reconsidering
what robots are doing as an application
domain the kinds of problems that we are
looking to solve are changing as well so
in manufacturing as an example it used
to be that we had these wonderful
assembly lines that were all robots and
we could precisely define everything in
the world and how things transition from
one pleast paste to another now we're
starting to see a desire to move towards
what's called collaborative
manufacturing where the idea is that
robots are good at some things and
they're terrible at other things they're
great at doing very high precision tasks
but they usually have terrible dexterity
they're not good at handling soft or
foldable materials and so what would
happen if we put people and robots
together in the same space now they're
certainly safe
d concerns with this and I'm not going
to touch on those today but those are
starting to become solvable problems so
what happens when we put this
unpredictable human into these
wonderfully well constrained robotic
domains and that changes a lot of our
basic assumptions so what we would like
to be able to do in the ideal world is
we'd like to keep many of the pillars
that we've already built and already
invested a lot of time and research
energy into we'd like to still be able
to observe these linearized sequences of
tasks these manipulation tasks and learn
from them we'd still like to be able to
use many of the existing methods that we
have for learning from demonstration and
many of the same models that we've been
building and we still need to focus on
execution policies we still need to be
able to focus on what it is that the
robots capable of doing given some state
around it but in order to adapt to these
interactive settings we're going to have
to change some of our fundamental
assumptions and I'm gonna try to make
three points today and I'm a firm
believer in always telling you what they
are before I make them so here they are
here's the whole point of the talk
number one we need to move away from
these flat representations they're just
not adequate for dealing with the
complexities that arise when you put
that unpredictable human in an
environment with the physical robot
second we need to move away from divide
and conquer based planning mechanisms
I'll tell you what that means in a few
minutes and finally we need to consider
collaboration in a very broad sense and
that means changing what is the desired
goal and the desired outcome of these
systems and what we optimize our
learning in order to be able to achieve
ok so let's take these one at a time
why do we want to move away from flat
representations well as we start to
interact with these higher and higher
dimensional spaces as we start to worry
more about safety and concerns that
operate over flexible and deformable
materials our search space becomes
really terrible so one of the benefits
of moving away from this flat structure
is that if we can somehow represent this
and break that space up if we can
somehow find a way of reducing the
dimensionality that's going to be a
giant benefit for us so hierarchical
structures and I'll use that in a
generic sense for a few minutes
hierarchical structures allow us to
break down the dimensionality of the
problem and deal with contained
subspaces that we can hopefully work
well with in the second big thing that
we get from this though is that we can
start talking about multi-agent task
allocation with a linearized sequence of
observations it's very hard to take that
sequence and convert it into some
paralyze Alexa queue ssin plan between a
robot and a human or even multiple
robots in multiple people that is with a
more structured approach with some type
of hierarchy will some type of
structured representation we can start
to identify portions of the tasks that
are perform about perhaps only by one
agent only the human can fold this piece
of material or only the human is
dexterous enough to get this tiny screw
into place and other things might only
be performed by the robot we only trust
the robot to do this high-temperature
arc welding and we could start looking
at the structure of this task and
thinking about it not just as a single
execution thread but as something that
we can optimize the performance by
dividing it up
the third benefit that we really gained
and this is perhaps the most important
that we actually right now have the
least to say about is that we gain some
transparency with the human in pod that
we're interacting with it's extremely
difficult to take these large flat
state-based representations and even
describe what's happening at that moment
in time knowing that you're in state
1732 doesn't give any information to
your human partner however knowing that
you're assembling the back leg of the
chair that's a much more useful piece of
information so it allows us to build
structure within these representations
that are communicative with the
individual now of course the
disadvantage of all of this is where do
we get this hierarchy from we have all
of these techniques and methods that are
designed to operate on these linearized
sequences of observations if I'm
swapping out the RAM in my laptop I
observed three different people doing it
are two different people doing it and
they follow a sequence of steps and
maybe they don't follow the exact same
sequence of steps but all I get are
these linearized sequences of
observations how do I take that and
extract some hierarchical representation
now there are good techniques out there
for doing it I'm going to show you one
really simple technique that I have to
credit Brad Hayes was my former grad
student with identifying which is that
we're going to treat this as a discovery
problem and we're gonna take those
traditional models that we use and just
consider the conjugate up though so
traditionally let's say we're assembling
that little chair that you saw a video
of a few minutes ago we would treat
states of the world real physical states
object locations tool locations
assemblies as nodes within this graph
and actions as transitions between one
state and another that is an action
allows us to transit
translate from one world state to
another what we're going to do is to
swap that and consider what we've been
calling a conjugate of this graph which
is that we're gonna consider actions to
be the nodes within this representation
and transitions will be the world states
that are required in order to enable
that action now the first thing to
notice is that we can automatically
derive this from the typical SM DP it's
trivial to be able to take one
representation and swap it in to the
other but once we're in this
representation we can start to look for
particular structure within that graph
and it becomes a recognition problem
within that graph space so what are the
structures were looking for well the
first thing we're gonna look for is that
we're gonna look for sequences or chains
of states because those chains of states
indicate sequences of actions that have
to be performed one after another the
other thing that we'll look for are
cliques fully connected sub graphs those
cliques will represent sequences or
rather collections of activities that
must all be performed but where the
order is invariant or sorry the order is
arbitrary we can perform those actions
in any order so let's take this example
so here's one of the little sub graphs
from this chair assembly task we'll look
through and we'll consider it first to
be one completely flat representation
that is there's one node in the
hierarchy that represents the whole
structure and each of the individual
nodes is an action within of the leaf of
that hierarchy will then start looking
for cliques and chains and will
iteratively look for those two
structures so first let's identify a
couple of chains so there's a pair of
chains here in which I have to get the
left peg and then place the left peg
into its into its position and I have to
get the right peg and place the right
peg into its position and I have to do
those in order and any time I start with
getting the left peg I
have to do getting the replacing the
left peg after that so we'll identify
those chains of activities we'll treat
those as a step up in the hierarchy and
will condense the nodes within that
graph and treat that as one entity now
once we do that we can then recognize
that now there is a clique in place here
that is from whatever where I go outside
of this entry
I always come in I come in to either one
of those two I didn't have to complete
the other before I move on and exit that
that is to say I have to do the left
side and I have to do the right side but
it doesn't matter which one I do first
and then finally there's one big chain
that I formed now between the starting
state this large purple intermediate
clique and then the two last actions and
that's one higher level structure so
what this does is that forms
hierarchical structure where the
internal or higher level nodes indicate
either actions that must be performed in
sequence the chains or can be performed
in any sequence those clicks now it's
certainly not the most intelligent
hierarchy it's so we could we could do
that it turns out that you can you can
create multiple hierarchies that are
identical and in fact you can you need
to define a way to have preference one
type of representation over another it's
the same as sort of the socks and shoes
problem I need to put on two socks and I
need to put on two shoes it doesn't
matter whether I do both socks then both
shoes or I do left sock left shoe left
right sock right shoe but there are
orderings that I can't do I can't do
left sock right shoe so we need to be
able to discriminate those and we do
have some methods and I don't have time
to talk about that but it is that is
something that we deliberately didn't
talk about right now today yeah
along the edges the sort of the
preconditions that are medium stated as
kind of a logical entity so in general
with that basically yeah so those can be
those are the same things that you're
gonna derive from looking at these world
states and what are the actions that are
being performed in order to transition
from one to the other those are those
are the same kinds of things that we get
from a learning from demonstration based
system yes there are a few things that
you need to do I've skipped over a
couple of steps here but there are a few
things you need to do to match up those
and to condense and simplify them all
right so that's one simple technique
that we can use to start to generate
some form of hierarchical structure let
me make the argument now that not only
do we need to build these structures so
that we have ways of communicating
between the person and the machine but
that we also need to change the way that
we consider what the machine is doing so
imagine that I'm putting this chair
together again typical methods that we
have for identifying what the robot
should do whether it's a hierarchical
based planning system or a flat based
planning system is to identify which
actions which subtasks could the robot
perform where every sub task that the
robot can identify is one step toward
the goal it's one of the leaf nodes in
this representation however that's a
very limited form of the kinds of
interactions that we see when we look at
real partner teams and let me again jump
to the the end of this story first there
are many other behaviors that you don't
find through a divide-and-conquer based
approach to planning there are useful
things for a collaborator to do
for example handing you material when
you need it or loosing that in this case
you're having trouble with one part and
maybe you would actually have a better
time with this screwdriver instead of
trying to put that screw in by hand or
being able to recognize that you're
having a lot of trouble getting this to
actually fit together and maybe what I
should do is just hold that piece of
material in place for you so that you
have fewer things that you have to
manipulate these kinds of things
I'm gonna call supportive behaviors none
of them are the kinds of actions that
you could find by a divide-and-conquer
based approach no divide-and-conquer
based approach to looking at the task of
assembling this chair is going to come
up with hold the material steady or hand
over the screwdriver doesn't matter what
level of granularity I pull this apart -
yes right so there's some things where
that's gonna be the case there are other
things like what I might do is I might
clear the workspace for you know part of
our planning system is going to identify
that okay me supporting the structure
you're already supporting the structure
why should I need to stabilize it for
you so we can depending upon the level
of granularity some of these may become
parts of the decomposition but there's
no level of granularity where we're
gonna get all of them so in this case we
had pre-programmed and the video you saw
we pre-programmed certain behaviors that
when a certain condition was triggered
the robot head would respond if it saw
that you were fumbling around and taking
too long on a particular task there was
a particular action that it offered
you're taking too long assembling the
back of the chair to the side of the
chair I'll offer to stabilize this for
you
we'd like to do better than that so in
most of our demonstration based systems
the human through some form of an
deliberate instruction tells the robot
what to do when to do it we'd like to
move to the point well we have moved to
the point where where's one step better
than that the robot recognizes when to
take an action but then it responds with
this one canned response we'd like the
robot to move beyond that to the point
where it figures not only how to help
what it should be doing but also when it
should intercede and help and that means
that we move a little bit from a
traditional learning perspective to what
in robotics would call planning but I'm
gonna argue that they're pretty similar
anyway so in order to do this we're
gonna link a symbolic planner with a
motion planning system and these are
typically considered as separate tasks
within the robotics world there's a
symbolic planner that tells me what
tasks I'm supposed to do and then a
motion based planner that tells me how
to execute that particular goal State
and we're gonna do some amount of
perspective taking that is we have to
consider things from the other agents
point of view in order to be able to do
this okay so I'm gonna highlight a
solution this is not the best solution
and this is not in any way the final
solution that we would like to have but
it's enough to give you a sense of what
the where the problems are so what we're
gonna try to do is we're going to have
the robot initially hypothesize future
States that is we're gonna generate
future hypothetical States that the
robot could achieve things that it could
possibly do based on the plans that it
has and the actions that are available
to it will then look at and predict what
the user might be able to do given that
future State
and figure out what the robot would need
to do in order to achieve that state
okay so imagine some point in the future
imagine what the human user would be
able to do going forward from that point
and going backwards figure out what it
would take me to get to that point well
then wait that policy and look at it and
say is this something that's worth doing
and if it is then let's execute it now
like I said this is not the perfect
solution ideally we'd like to have some
more guidance than just imagine a bunch
of possible future states but for now
that's gonna be good enough all right so
let me give you some examples with a
simplified assembly task so rather than
building a chair now I'm gonna build
some flat pack furniture that involves a
small bench okay it's got four pieces
it's got two legs a horizontal support
and a flat piece to sit on the bench
itself and we've made our job somewhat
easier and that we've put QR tags on
these so that we don't have to solve
lots of difficult vision problems
because we've got enough problems to
give everyone we'll let the vision
community figure that out
okay so here's some of the supportive
actions that in this case a Baxter robot
a commercial robot could use in terms of
constructing supportive behaviors for
that assembly so the robot has a
sequence of part pieces that it can grab
here it's going to offer to hold one of
the pieces in place while it provides
the other components to a human user and
we're showing this at four times speed
because even with the best that we're
doing now the robots are still kind of
slow and we run them deliberately slow
to keep things safe in the lab but this
is the kind of activity that we're
trying to generate now no part of the
plan here involves deliberately giving
the robot instructions about handing one
object over to its other hand about
holding that steady
now we are using some simplified vision
as I said to do this the QR tags as you
can see are letting us localize this and
select out pieces but it also introduces
one interesting piece which is that we
can make small changes to these pieces
so that some of them fit together and
others don't and the robot can
discriminate between them and the human
user can't so it allows us to build and
represent a terse or build a very simple
task where there are some things that
the human is not good at or that we want
to not allow the human partner to do and
this is an online planning process so
there will be failures that come along
in this case we're going to generate a
failure by having the human user come
along and select decide that one of the
pieces is faulty and get rid of it at
which point the robot needs to adapt
what it's doing and replan on the fly to
generate not only the actions that
needed to be done to support assembling
this piece but also those supportive
actions as well
and finally we can also start to model
preferences in terms of tasks activity
so we may have one user who likes to
assemble things and then put the you
know put the two legs together and then
put it down and put the bench on and
other users who might prefer to do
everything while the robot is holding
things so the challenge is here and this
is again just a system that's designed
enough to give you a set of ideas about
what should happen next is how can we
look at this kind of a process and build
a representation that allows the robot
to flexibly select and learn to select
those different kinds of supportive
activities all right let me take this
one step further
once we start considering supportive
action in addition to just tasks based
on or or tasks directed activity we need
to think about the kinds of ways in
which we model collaboration and I'm
gonna do this with a different
application domain we're still gonna use
an industrial-grade robot but we're
gonna use a very simple kids toy to
demonstrate this so this is a electronic
building kit called snap circuits where
the idea is you've got these rigid
pieces that are wires and these rigid
pieces that are resistors and these
rigid pieces that are battery packs and
you can build circuits out of them by
connecting them together and just
clicking them together it's nice because
it's the kind of thing that we can
easily characterize it's also great
because while there's a limited search
space for this you can only put them
down on certain pegs you can't sort of
position them any which way you want
there's still a relatively rich
description of the way in which you can
define problems and not have a specific
solution in mind so I can ask you to
build a switch to light bulb and there's
there's not an infinite number of
solutions but there's a large number of
solutions given a finite set of parts ok
this brings din to the forefront
problems with resource allocation who's
gonna grab which piece at which time how
do we use the space of the board how do
we assign who's doing which piece and
how do we paralyze those different
subtasks now we're gonna use this same
supportive agent pipeline but the piece
that I'm gonna focus on in the piece
that I'm gonna modify in order to make
this point is this magic little piece up
here that says somehow we wait the two
policies between the human and the
Machine predicted action that the human
would take if the robot carried out this
one supportive or tasks based activity
how do we wait those two when we
consider the full execution okay so we
can capture this by
evaluation function and for right now
we're just gonna consider duration as
our key metric okay how long does it
take you to complete this task all right
so we're gonna minimize over all of the
possible activities that we could take
which support policy should we be
selecting that minimizes that duration
now the only part to this that we're
going to do anything to change at all
is this weighting function that we're
applying to the duration so there's a
fixed duration for every possible
configuration of the world of what would
take to go next and we'll weight them in
different ways so one thing we could do
is we could just apply a uniform
weighting function put a W of one a
constant one in there and what that's
going to do is it's going to make the
robot take some action that will
optimize or improve one of the possible
plans that are out there so in this case
we're using a smaller cuca robot arm but
it's actually a much more dangerous
robot to be around so we run it much
much slower this is an
industrial-strength robot it's powerful
enough to tear itself off the table so
think of what it can do to your fingers
and that's why we run it slow so that's
the only reason it's moving at the speed
it will you'll see it so what's gonna
happen is we have these different pieces
from the snap circuits available on the
table in these little cups so they're
easy for the robot to grab and a human
who's got a specific task in mind in
this case they're trying to build a
switch to led and there's one nice three
wire component there and there's another
three wire component theorem and if we
use a uniform weighting function the
robot is gonna take some possible plan
and optimize it in this case it's gonna
take that three element wire that's
really far away from the person and move
it close to them because there's a
possibility that they would use that
piece however it's extremely unlikely
planned because they already have a
three wire piece right in front of them
the robot has made one possible plan
better but there's already a better plan
out there so there's really no reason
for this to happen yes so there's
there's a there's a piece that is what
should the robot do and then based on
the state that that ends up in what is
the human action that we predict will
happen following that all right second
thing we could try
and instead optimize with a slightly
different weighting function where we'll
wait the plans proportional to the
similarity to the best known solution so
the closer you are to the best known
solution the best solution that we have
it planned at this point the better
we'll wait it so what that's gonna do
for us is we will in effect favor making
our good plans even better so in this
case the person is assembling again the
same circuit we see that they've
selected a part we know which part
they're going to potentially need or
which part kind of parts they're gonna
need to finish that off and the robot
will go take that piece that we know
that they're going to need next and make
it easier for them to get that piece
in some of these situations it seems
like each would be yes absolutely this
is a situation where yeah and that's and
that's there are times when speech is
essential and and we can talk about that
that's actually one of the things we're
working with right now it's a very hard
domain to integrate speech into because
the kinds of utterances that you get
from the human are extraordinarily
difficult to ground the person in this
case will say you know get me the next
piece what's the next piece or the most
common utterance that we actually get
when we have real people do this is
they'll just say help Thanks you know
that that's great that need that means I
know you want some me to do something
now but it hasn't given me any selection
over what that action should be let me
give you one other thing and this is
this is the point I wanted to get to one
of the other ways in which we can modify
that waiting function is that we can
penalize bad plans so rather than trying
to make a good plan better
we will penalize the really poor
performing plans ok effectively make a
bad plan worse what this accounts what
this amounts to is the robot basically
assuming that it knows better than you
and it doesn't trust you not to do
something that might look like a good
plan to you but is really a terrible
idea
so for example in this video we're gonna
have a plan that it would be a terrible
plan to execute using the wrong piece
but that piece that they're considering
is this sub optimal but easy to reach
peace so normally when we consider
planning what we would do is we would
take one of the three components three
length pieces one of the good pieces and
move it close to you but if we change
this weighting function instead what the
robot does
as it takes that easily available but
faulty piece and moves it so that it's
really hard for you to get to it this is
a different kind of collaboration okay
this is the kind of thing that we need
to start considering it's not the case
that we would want to do this all the
time in fact it would be nice to have a
model of how expert your system is and
how expert the user is and adjust the
weighting function based on that but we
do this with each other when I sit down
and I teach one of my brand new
undergraduate lab assistants how to
solder you can bet that I take the
really expensive parts and I move them
really far away from them so that they
don't try those out first so when we
start considering real collaborations
situations we need to move beyond the
idea of just optimizing the best plan
sometimes optimizing the best plan is
the really the best thing we can do but
sometimes maybe we want to take one of
those bad plans and make it even worse
okay let me close up and then I'll take
both questions I just need to say thanks
to the people who actually did all of
the work for this Brad Hayes who was my
former PhD student who's now at Julie
Shaw's lab at MIT
Alessandro Olivier and Francesca
Alessandro and Olivier are my current
postdocs and francesco is a visiting
student and that's thanks to all of them
for supporting the robots as well okay
let me go back and take questions so
first in the back and then right perfect
sense I just wondered currently are
these behaviors learned from past
experience because it all boils down to
theory of mind yes
actually she tried to really grab that
for peace yeah so there's there's
definitely a question of how would the
person respond to this particular action
okay one of the things that we have the
robots do naturally or not naturally
there is no such thing as naturally for
a robot one of the things that the room
that falls out of either any of these
kinds of planning is that the robot will
actively if it has nothing better to do
it will actively try to make your job
easier by pulling things out of the way
that are not relevant to the task at
hand so effectively it cleans up the
workspace we like that in part because
what it's doing effectively it's
limiting the cognitive load on the user
and if you trust the robot then that's
an effective thing for it to do if you
don't trust the robot though it's a
terrible thing to do because every time
the robot grabs something and takes it
away from me I'm immediately thinking
wait maybe I want that and it distracts
the user every time so there are a lot
of different kinds of scenarios that we
might consider as we look at these and
it definitely comes down to a bit of
theory of mind and perspective-taking
and that's what I mean that's a lot of
my interest in this
and one of the things and one of the
things that we can do because this is
represented in in a non flat system is
that we can actually either deliberately
ask the robot what are you doing now and
it can say I'm assembling the the rear
leg structure or it can say you looked
like you were having trouble I'm
offering to help or it can say you
really don't need this I'm just getting
it out of the way and those are things
that we can identify internally as
structure one of the current projects
that we are have right now is that we're
working with to natural language folks
to try to produce those kinds of
grounded utterances it's not something
we have the capability to do right now
but it's something that we are
structured to do that's exactly the in
this particular instance yes but not
always and that's and that's one of the
things actually that we use as an active
learning mechanism to figure out whether
something is part of the task or not so
when the robot doesn't know the task at
all one thing you can do to figure out
whether something is important is to try
to get rid of it and as soon when you
get stopped you suddenly know that's an
important piece it sounds silly to some
extent but when you're trying to
identify you know there there are three
parts to this ideally what we would have
in my wonderful vision of the future is
that we would effectively do what
surgeons call their mechanism for watch
one do one teach one
so you watch it first watch someone else
do it then you work together and you do
it collaboratively and then you bring in
somebody new who's never done it before
and you have to teach the process to
that
closing that loop between those three
very what we consider very different
tasks right now watch somebody and learn
how to do this learning from
demonstration collaborate with someone
okay maybe this kind of stuff teach them
how to do it
we have other work that's on that
tutoring side of the domain but how do
you build something that actually spans
across those three domains that's what I
think is the really interesting part to
this but you're not going to get it
unless you have the underlying
representation right yeah absolutely
even in the real even in really simple
things we have even when we're building
those little likea chairs we bring in
naive users we give them a set of
instructions they study the instructions
and then we say here you go build the
chair okay some people love this kind of
thing sure enough we bring in a couple
of Mickey undergrads and this is you
know fun time for them we're a liberal
arts campus you bring in a theater
studies major and this maybe is not
their kind of thing and they're
miserable with it those two different
individuals have different preferences
about what they want to do and what they
want help with now those are caricatures
of people obviously I know theater study
folks who are much better at assembling
things than unfortunately some of the
meki students but those kinds of
preferences come across we want the
system to be able to identify those yeah
so you know one of the reasons we cast
this in the collaborative manufacturing
domain is the idea that you're going to
be working together for a reasonable
amount of time you're gonna be doing
some things repetitively but you are
going to be changing tasks as you go
along and that's the kind of thing that
you're seeing small and medium scale
enterprises being interested in if
you're mercedes-benz or your Volkswagen
you can afford to dedicate a
multi-million dollar factory towards one
protect
their line of product if you're the
local bakery you can't do that so
instead you need a system that's going
to be flexible enough where in the
morning it's helping I don't know box
croissants to send out for the morning
deliveries and later in the afternoon
it's helping to roll out dough how do
you how do you shift between these
different kinds of things so as I
promised I brought more problems than
solutions today but these are the kinds
of things that I think make for
interesting collaboration across domains
so it turns out that the surgeons so
this is one thing uh so our natural
language collaborators are actually
worked in the medical domain before this
and it's one of the things where
surgeons are very particular about the
staff that they work with because they
learn the patterns of what's expected
and the worst thing you can do to a
surgeon is to give them a different
scrub nurse there they're basically you
know the thing you want to know going
into surgery is that this team has
worked together before a lot that's the
best predictor of success and it's
because it's not the case that everyone
has a very well-defined job different
people have preferences and those just
the overall responsibilities are the
same but the distribution of them when
they happen how they happen it's not the
same from team to team
okay I think I kept us mostly on time
[Applause]
okay so the next speaker is talking
about active learning the nearest
neighbor